to the girl on Facebook who commented
hashtag all lives matter
after deeming the protest she attended a
hateful event Martin Luther King would
have been ashamed of call it an
overreaction call it a riot a violent
protest call it everything but justified
asked us to be polite to stay calm to
voice grief with respect while our
brother's bodies are laid out on the
street sounding the alarm our bodies our
threats well before they are human and
you still want to know the source of our
rage you fear our rage will happen
across the storefront window will happen
across a corporate office you fear the
glass shards glittering under police
helicopters we fear your rage will drag
our children into the streets and dance
in the red pool beaming under street
lamps I cannot decorate this pain for
you I cannot make a beautiful omage I
can't invoke hope in prayer I don't know
how to make you understand the
occupation your ignorance has blinded
you to that black bodies are stopped and
frisked so often we might as well call
our cities war zones every street corner
a checkpoint violence is not always a
dead body violence can be a pat-down in
broad daylight because you share the
same hue as suspect violence as in
dining the man who filmed the killing of
Eric garner but not the officer that
illegally choked the life out of his
body while five others assisted in the
arrest of violence is convincing a jury
that he caused his own death that had he
not been overweight he would have
survived violence as needing six
officers to arrest one unarmed
non-violent man in the first place how
can we accept a government that only
applies the law to fill prisons with
blackbodies how can we accept a
government that permits and perpetuates
violence against its people the state
traded white hoods for police uniforms
and you want our marches peaceful you
want us calm you want us quiet stop
asking us to bite our tongues when we
cannot guarantee our siblings safe
passage to the corner store yet you
still want to talk about looting want to
police our protest tactics you want me
to know that you would have cared about
the tombstones this nation is hoarding
if we hadn't blocked traffic you think
stopping trains is silly you want us to
march peacefully to replicate your
disfigured perception of Martin but dr.
King said riots are the voices of the
unheard and you will hear us now it is
not enough for you to hold our dead in
your prayers to wish us love and light I
get the sentiment but it won't keep my
kin from becoming ghosts I am NOT
interested in resignations or remorse
I don't want apologies I don't want your
guilt I don't want your tears
I don't want insistence on how not
racist you are I don't want to know how
many black friends you have when you
won't even risk the discomfort of
calling out your own classmates you just
don't get it do you you've never lived
out the aftermath the empty seat at the
dinner table the now widowed mother with
six mouths to feed my kin are being sent
to heaven well before God has requested
their return and you want to know why
Malcolm called whiteness the devil all
lives will matter when black lives
matter how many more bodies will be
enough evidence how many videos of our
last words how many more must there be
for you to finally call this a genocide